death loop's black reef changed the way
i play games and made me behave in a way
that's not in my nature the role i
inhabit is that of a ghost entering a
scenario to achieve an objective and
leaving with clean hands and conscience
i'm the pebble thrown into water that
makes no ripples and yet in death loop i
murdered hundreds of eternalists and i
felt good about doing it the allure of
black reefs daily absolution which wipes
the slate clean for each new time loop
was difficult to resist and killing
became second nature but this leads you
to ask when nothing matters how do you
give your actions meaning that's where
developer arcane leon's gameplay design
comes into play and killing with abandon
becomes killing for a reason to break
the loop
oh
that was one
ridiculous name
ah i gotta snap drink it
the mechanics of death loop are
constructed so masterfully that there's
a tangible sense of growth both in game
and out of it but what's most impressive
about death loop is that it's also an
introspective game it's arcane
deconstructing its own brand of
open-ended action the systems are
presented as digestible and the game
subtly pushes you to put the pieces
together so you can truly appreciate how
it all ticks it's a game where
observation and dynamic thinking go hand
in hand with shotgunning goons in the
face and it delivers bombastic thrills
with intelligence and elegance in equal
measure at the heart of the game is colt
van a man simultaneously adrift in time
and stuck within it he wakes up on a
beach with no memory of how he got there
or what's really going on however what
distinguishes him from the other
hedonistic denizens of black reef is
that he's able to retain his memory
between loops and very soon he discovers
that a strange element called residueum
can be harnessed to give his arsenal of
weaponry and supernatural abilities
permanence too deathloop is a
fascinating mashup of styles and vibes
underpinning the world is a kind of
retro future science that is incredibly
effective at giving the world texture
think time travel by way of 1960s
computers that fill a room and look like
they have less power than an original
iphone complementing that is an element
of the supernatural that is essentially
time science harnessed by a mad genius
to give a chosen few the ability to do
things like teleport link the fate of
other people together
or become almost invisible amongst other
things these abilities are bestowed to
the visionaries an eclectic group of
elites that the rank and file are sworn
to protect so that their life of
indulgence can remain eternal colt's
goal is to kill these visionaries and in
doing so break the time loop the rob is
that it needs to be done in one day a
single loop easier said than done given
that the game operates on a night and
day cycle where over the course of the
loop each visionary has their own
routine and life to lead complicating
matters further is the fact that the
visionaries know cult is out to get them
and in fact all of them have some sort
of pre-existing relationship with him
[Music]
one in particular juliana takes it upon
herself to be the thorn in colt's side
she serves the role of antagonist but
the situation is clearly complicated
between them their interpersonal dynamic
is placed front and center to drive much
of the narrative and characterization
and both characters are realized
exceptionally well juliana is the voice
in colt's ear and also over blackreach's
loudspeakers and she does her damnedest
to get under his skin she picks at him
in a way that only someone with a deep
personal connection to you can using
insight into his personality and history
to constantly undermine him and poke at
his neuroses and yet there's also a
sweetness to their interactions at times
like a couple in the heat of an argument
remembering for just a moment why they
care about each other in a very real
sense juliana is a pure agent of chaos
it's worth pointing out that the voice
acting is absolutely crucial to selling
this relationship and in that regard
it's achieved exceptionally well i'm
done playing this your way it's the cult
show from now on
okay
all aboard sweetie
i said colt show not coat
for his part colt eventually engages her
in the verbal joust and starts getting
under her skin the constant back and
forth between the two is a genuine joy
to listen to and the writing is sharp to
make the development of their
relationship feel natural black reef is
split up into multiple districts and
each one is usually home to at least one
of the visionaries colt's objective is
to enter an area figure out how to get
himself into a position where he can
kill said visionary and take their slab
an item that gives them one of six
unique supernatural abilities but each
of the visionaries is
a weirdo charlie for example has set up
a low budget escape room harriet is
hosting a group of wellness sessions
that is as sinister as it sounds while
wenji rarely ever leaves her lab death
loops day and night cycle also means
that these visionaries are only
available at certain times of the day
although you can manually progress time
to your needs there's only ever a
specific window of opportunity to kill a
visionary that means you need to play
through time loops repeatedly puzzling
out a plan to execute it when a time is
right the game makes this more
manageable by giving the player
visionary leads to follow you may need
the code to a door in one area for
example but a ledger with that
information is being stored in an office
elsewhere so you also kind of get a tour
of black reef through this you're slowly
trained to develop a meticulous
understanding of each area in the game
and as your cult grows in strength and
capabilities so too does your
proficiency in navigating them after
killing a visionary you gain a power
which can be used in the following time
loops provided you invest residium into
them residium can be extracted from
charged objects in the environment or
from the dead body of a visionary
spending this resource allows you to
hold on to tools between loops slab
powers are the most essential as they
give you a significant ability and
killing a visionary repeatedly to take
their slab will evolve the power the
shift power for example lets you
teleport much like dishonours blink but
repeatedly killing the visionary
wielding it and collecting it will allow
you to upgrade the power to let you swap
places with an enemy
trinkets are also littered throughout
the world weapon trinkets can be used to
augment your combat abilities while
personal trinkets enhance cult's
physical performance the presence of
these is what makes each time loop
consistently rewarding to play through
sometimes it can be good to do a run
through an area or even entire loop to
build your residual balance and collect
some more trinkets especially since it's
also an opportunity to refine your
chosen playstyle a bit more and since
cole is able to come back from death
twice there is a degree of forgiveness
in the game that really encourages you
to do wacky things when the opportunity
arises that third death however will
reset the time loop entirely so some
strategy is also required if you want to
make the most of your time the
based design of death loop eases you
into creating a flow state that you can
enter into and exit from at will with
the character development system it
gamifies trial and error so effectively
that failures almost always still feel
like small triumphs this might sound
typical of a roguelike game but death
loop's gameplay feels entirely of its
own brand and that's because it's built
on the foundation of arcane's domino
effect design that is especially
apparent as you uncover dead ends
documents peppered around the world will
provide a small lead on something which
is then marked as a discovery and the
game does an excellent job of creating a
breadcrumb trail around black reef for
you to follow and it always leads to
something meaningful whether it's
finding the cold to open a locked door
or figuring out how to manipulate two
visionaries into appearing at the same
place at the same time you're never more
than a run or two away from having an
epiphany in many regards death loop is a
game about being meticulous and arcane
has done a fantastic job in making the
act of just being in the world looking
around and listening to it enthralling
it should come as no surprise that black
reef is absolutely stunning to behold
given the strong sense of art direction
that the studio's previous games have
had each of the four areas of the game
has a distinct style which changes
depending on the time of day thanks to
lighting and even weather effects of
particular note are the 60s esque
interiors that are somehow both
beautiful and utterly garish in a way
that only retro furniture can be wooden
walls shocking red pleather couches that
look like they would make your ass numb
after a minute of sitting on them and
oddly contorted lighting fixtures will
stop you in your tracks so you can ogle
at how odd they are but they also fit
into the aesthetic so perfectly that you
can't help but be impressed by the
interior design chops being displayed
needless to say arcane sense of art
direction remains impeccable and for my
money unmatched and complementing it is
the raucous soundtrack that is as
eclectic and as unexpected as the visual
stylings continuing the mash-up of
styles and themes death loop transitions
effortlessly between disparate styles to
suit the needs of the moment from a
cinematic standpoint but also has you
tapping your feet along to the chaos
happening on screen death loop's gun
play is weighty and satisfying and a
great deal of the thrill that comes from
trading lead is elevated by the
brilliant funky soundtrack
the final piece to death loop's gameplay
puzzle is multiplayer which manifests
itself in two distinct ways the first is
technically not multiplayer as it sees
an ai controlled juliana invade colt's
game to try and assassinate him at
random points the game announces that
juliana has invaded and locked the exit
points out of the area the only way to
get out is hack a specific point to
unlock the exit tunnels but to do that
you usually have to go through her these
moments are genuinely terrifying
especially when you're on a good run
juliana is capable of masking her
appearance to look like any random
eternalist so she could really be
anywhere and anyone of course a human
player someone on your friend's list a
random person on the internet or even
you can choose to protect the loop by
assuming the role of juliana as the
hunter you invade cult's world to kill
him and the ability to mimic npcs is
unique to juliana and extremely
versatile especially if you have a good
understanding of the world the sense of
tension this introduces to gameplay is
exhilarating as you never know when a
juliana could appear to turn your world
upside down it hearkens back to the kind
of hide and seek multiplayer introduced
in assassin's creed brotherhood and the
pvp of the soulsborne games and it works
really well within death loop of course
you can opt not to allow people to
invade you too if you'd prefer a purely
single player experience
[Music]
perhaps the most laudable part of death
loop is how it takes so many seemingly
disparate things and creates harmony
between them gameplay systems that feel
isolated become pieces of a bigger
puzzle and when you see how they
seamlessly connect together you realize
just how special of an achievement it
really is similarly on paper the
different aesthetics should be like oil
and water but they come together
effortlessly to be part of a greater
whole and for me that's what death loop
is really about by standing back and
looking at the bigger picture the
uncharacteristic choices and the
unexpected behaviors feel necessary
essential even maybe it's just what i
need to believe to give all that killing
meaning but when i began the final loop
and carved a perfect bloody path through
black reefs visionaries in a single day
i made no ripples
[Music]
juliana
juliana you there
juliana
i remember your name
whatever